this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business check out squarespace
through the link in the description
below
more about them in a bit
we're back in the prohibition era the
time of gangsters bootleggers
and public enemies number one the time
of notorious criminals such as
bonnie and clyde john dillinger and of
course
today's subject machine gun kelly
despite his strong association with bank
robberies they were not what brought
kelly everlasting infamy
and turned him into a household name no
it was in fact the kidnapping
of a ritual magnate it wasn't just the
act itself that mattered
but also the circumstances america was
still reeling from the kidnapping and
murder of charles lindbergh's baby boy
all eyes were on this case as everyone
feared that another high-profile
kidnapping would have the same tragic
end and
that's how george machine gun kelly
became the most wanted man in america
[Music]
right off the bat we have some
conflicting information as sources seem
uncertain
where and when machine gun kelly was
born we're going to use his alcatraz rap
sheet since that is an official record
and according to it george kelly barnes
was
born in chicago illinois in 1895. he
actually came from well-off family and
was the son of george senior and
elizabeth kelly barnes his father was a
successful insurance company exec but he
and george never really got along
according to one story when he was a
teenager george found out that his
father was having an affair he then
proceeded to blackmail his father for
keeping his secret in exchange for a
larger allowance in the use of the
family car when kelly was two years old
the family relocated to memphis
tennessee there he attended idlewild
elementary school and then central high
school where he was a mediocre student
his mother died while he was still in
high school and this devastated george
was very close to her
it also further widened the rift between
him and his father as george blamed his
affairs for his mother's passing after
graduating george kelly briefly enrolled
in college studying
agriculture at mississippi a m today
known as mississippi state university
because he knew this is what his mother
wanted for him however
he was clearly not made for college life
he racked up dozens of demerits in his
first few months and was expelled at the
beginning of his second semester
while in high school kelly had already
started his life of crime
at that point national prohibition was
still a few years away but already was
active in tennessee
which had the dubious honor of passing
the first prohibition law in the nation
therefore kelly had been using his car
to do a little bootlegging he
thought about going back to it once he
was out of college but he met someone
who set him straight
at least for the time being her name was
geneva ramsey and
the two of them fell in love and eloped
in 1919. she brought kelly to her home
where her father george ramsay had a
positive influence on him ramsay was a
successful levy contractor and he gave
his new son-in-law a job as a clerk in
his company the two
got along well and it seemed like george
kelly might live a respectable life
after all
where not for a tragic accident a few
years later where george ramsay killed
himself
with a stick of dynamite things went
downhill fast for the family after that
without ramsay in charge his company
struggled and his wife eventually sold
it
george and geneva had a few business
adventures such as running a goat farm
and
selling used cars but they all quickly
went under and in a few years george
kelly was driving a cab to make ends
meet his family life
also got significantly worse kelly
became a heavy drinker and he abused his
wife both mentally and physically they
had two sons together but for some
reason kelly always resented his first
child and
showed favoritism towards the second his
wife left him several times but kept
returning after george convinced her
to give him another chance however as
she saw him turn to a life of crime she
finally left him for good geneva
divorced kelly in 1926 and
she had to post the divorce notice in
the paper because by that point she no
longer had any idea where he was that's
because kelly
went back to something more lucrative
bootlegging moonshine by now
prohibition was in full effect so kelly
knew there was a lot of money to be made
but he also had to stay
on the move in order to evade the
authorities he didn't do a very good job
at it though and several arrests came in
the years that followed in tennessee
new mexico and oklahoma his bootlegging
career came to a temporary end in 1928
after that last arrest in tulsa which
earned kelly
a three-year stint at leavenworth
penitentiary
[Music]
despite the fearsome reputation he would
later develop kelly was
usually a model prisoner while
incarcerated in fact
years later while at alcatraz some of
the other inmates mockingly referred to
him
as pop gun kelly instead of machine gun
kelly because he was far less brutal and
violent than
one would expect of course this mortal
behavior did have its benefits
during his first incarceration at
leavenworth kelly was released early in
after serving less than two years he was
ready to resume his life of crime but
this time
he didn't do it alone soon after kelly
entered the bootlegging business again
he met catherine thorne the two of them
quickly fell in love and
by the end of 1930 they were married the
new mrs kelly was the antithesis of the
first one
she was a tough and hardened woman who
had already been married three times and
was a lifelong criminal
mainly she dealt in bootlegging but she
had also been suspected of killing her
third husband charlie thorne although
the coroner ultimately ruled his death a
suicide she had no objections to
george kelly's life as an outlaw and she
eagerly joined him in all of his
illegitimate benches
in fact most people credit catherine
kelly with creating her husband's
cold-blooded image even
gifting him his first tommy gun and
coming up with the machine gun kelly
nickname she also started a lot of
rumors about osmond's prowess with the
tommy gun and even
gave out spent cartridges to friends and
acquaintances as a way of increasing the
legend of machine gun kelly of all the
tall tales
involving kelly the most famous one
which has often been replicated in pop
culture
was that he could use a machine gun to
spell out his last name and bullet holes
spence that he did this to
sign his robberies there is some
evidence to suggest that kelly did do
this once on a signpost in texas but it
was certainly
not something that he did regularly
despite his continued association with
bootlegging after his release from
leavenworth machine gun kelly turned
primarily to robbery especially as
prohibition was winding down he
committed his first one in 1930 with
some friends he made in prison including
other notorious criminals of that era
such as harvey bailey thomas holden and
francis keating these four would
continue to pull off robberies together
but on this particular job
they were also joined by infamous
prohibition-era gunman vernon miller and
a few others
miller became well known for his role in
a shootout known as the kansas city
massacre but even on this occasion
he had an itchy trigger finger opening
fire on bystanders and later killing one
of the other robbers for double-crossing
him after keating and holden were
arrested in 1932
kelly formed a partnership with fellow
criminal albert bates and the duo
committed a string of robberies
throughout the year their biggest score
was in colfax washington where the two
of them and another robber named eddie
bence made off with 77 thousand dollars
from
the first trust and savings bank of
colfax which is about 1.5 million
dollars today kelly's last known bank
robbery took place in november 1932 when
he
bates and the third man stole 38 000
from citizen state bank in tupelo
mississippi it was
somewhat notable because for whatever
reason on that particular occasion kelly
decided to forego his signature tommy
gun and
instead committed the robbery armed with
a revolver now before we go any further
with machine gun kelly we've got a quick
word from today's video sponsor
squarespace you know what's great about
the summer
vacation time off a little bit of r r
it's the perfect time to spend
lying on the beach or in the park jay
dreaming about what that next project
that you want to start might be
fortunately squarespace gives you
every possible tool you could want to
make that dream into a reality
whether it's a small business a sports
blog a creative portfolio or just a page
of the dankest of dank memes it doesn't
matter if you can dream it you can build
it with squarespace are you looking to
get in and out quick without thinking
too much about
what your website should look like well
bam use one of their quick and beautiful
templates to make a website that's fresh
and for you or maybe you're more of a
hands-on person you've got lots of
opinions and ideas about
what exactly a site should look like
while squarespace gives you all the
customization options you could ever
want with no updates no patches no
technical bs to worry about and once
you've done updating your website
tinkering with the design if you're so
inclined or maybe just playing with the
colors there are so many extra features
that squarespace provides
the website can thrive email campaigns
patronage portal
social integrations member only areas
analytics commercial options 24 7
customer support
is everything you could ever want all in
one place so when you're ready to get
started on the next project of yours big
or small
if it involves a website it's got to be
with squarespace right now you can go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch your new
site
go to squarespace.com forward slash
biographics to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain and let's get back to today's
video
[Music]
despite his success as a bank robber
george kelly also tried his hand at
kidnapping where he proved himself to be
considerably less adept according to
some sources his first kidnapping
occurred in 1930 when kelly and a former
cop named bernard phillips
abducted a pair of victims only to have
one of them get killed in an accident
then in january 1932 kellyanne a man
called eddie doll kidnapped a banker
from
south bend indiana named howard
wolverton
first while the banker and his wife were
driving around kelly forced himself
inside the car at gunpoint and made
wolverton drive a few miles out of town
the pair then got into a waiting getaway
vehicle leaving mrs wilberton with a
fifty thousand dollar ransom note kelly
and dole drove there captive around
indiana for a couple of days before
wolverton persuaded them that
he simply did not have the money they
wanted so they released him on the
promise that he would raise the funds
later despite receiving a few
threatening calls and letters the banker
obviously never fulfilled his promise
for a third attempt kelly got his wife
involved the couple wanted to kidnap the
son of a rich old tycoon from fort worth
texas to accomplish this
catherine kelly approached two fort
worth detectives she believed were
corrupt to see if they wanted in on the
score unfortunately for her the cops
were honest and only played along
because they thought they could turn
catherine into an informant when they
realized that this was not the case they
turned down the offer and placed the
intended target under surveillance
forcing the kellys to abandon their plan
kidnappings were growing in popularity
among outlaws of the time because they
were considered to be lower risk than
bank robberies and they only involved
local or state law enforcement however
that soon changed following the
notorious lindbergh baby case when the
infant son of aviator charles nan
lindbergh was
kidnapped from his home only to be found
dead a few days later
the case which was on the front page of
every newspaper in america shocked and
outraged the public and
after the boy's death the federal
kidnapping act also known as the
lindbergh law was passed now kidnappings
became a federal matter
as fbi agents and u.s marshals could
easily pursue kidnappers who cross state
lines
the punishments also became much harsher
often resulting in
a life sentence in some states
kidnapping even qualified for the death
penalty of the victim had been
physically harmed for criminals the
raised stakes meant that they needed to
up their game and
only go after rich targets so that the
rewards would outweigh the risks in
early summer 1933 the barker and carpus
gang successfully executed the
high-profile kidnapping of brewery
tycoon william hamm
and received a hundred thousand dollars
for their troubles with money like that
on the line it's no wonder the criminals
were willing to take a chance
inspired by the ham kidnappings the
kellys decided to target their own rich
businessman
an all tycoon from oklahoma city named
charles urschel on the night of july
22nd 1933 ursula and his wife were
playing bridge with mr and mrs walter
jarrett on the porch of their home when
two armed men walked up to them one of
them was george kelly waving around his
signature tommy gun the other one armed
with only a pistol was his frequent
partner albert bates the two criminals
demanded to know which one of the men
was charles urschel since no response
was forthcoming they decided to kidnap
both men
obviously as soon as they were gone the
wives went inside and called the police
they were put straight through to j
edgar hoover director of the fbi and
both local police officers and fbi
agents were on the scene within the hour
meanwhile the kidnappers drove for about
12 miles outside of the city limits at
which point they stopped to ascertain
which one of the two men was their
intended target
they went through their wallets and
released walter jarrett who then began
his long walk back home afterwards
charles urschel was
taken to a ranch in paradise texas owned
by catherine kelly's stepfather robert
shannon that night the businessman was
kept inside the garage until bedtime at
which point he was blindfolded
and taken inside the house here he was
chained to an iron bed the following day
shaw was moved to a shack where he was
kept handcuffed to a high chair
and slept on a quilt by monday
herschel's kidnapping was headline news
across the country hoover took an active
role in the investigation as he was
eager to avoid another scandal like the
limburg case his agents were busy
running leads all over the united states
when the kidnappers finally made contact
on july the 22nd
they reached out to another oil magnate
and close friend of herschel's named
j g kepler who received a package
through western union
it contained a letter for him asking him
to act as an intermediary in the
kidnapping
a personal letter for herschel's wife
and a third letter with instructions
addressed to mr e kirkpatrick of
oklahoma city the ransom demands were
nothing out of the ordinary the
kidnappers wanted two hundred thousand
dollars in used twenty dollar bills
they also warned against using
sequential serial numbers dummy packages
and
any other kind of shenanigans that would
have resulted in herschel suffering a
consequences
to show that they agreed to the terms
urschel's camp was supposed to place an
ad in the daily oklahoman which read
for sale 160 acres land good five room
house deep well
also cows tools tractor corn and hay 3
750 for quick sale kirkpatrick did as he
was told
and he received another letter two days
later postmarked joplin missouri
this time with more specific
instructions he was supposed to put the
money in a light-colored leather bag and
board a certain train to kansas city
missouri throwing the bag off the
observation platform after
receiving a signal because the fbi's
main concern was to bring ursulin alive
they
did not get involved with the handoff
they did take some precautions though
sending catlett along with kirkpatrick
carrying two identical briefcases
one filled with money the other with old
newspapers other than that kirkpatrick
followed the instructions to a tee but
no signal to throw the briefcase ever
came
he arrived in kansas city still holding
the money fortunately for everyone
involved there was a contingency plan in
case something like this happened
kirkpatrick was to check in at the
mullibark hotel in kansas city under the
name
e kincaid there he received a message
from the kidnappers telling him to take
the money and travel alone west of the
lasalle hotel
for a few blocks there one of the
kidnappers simply approached him and
took the bag
on july 31 after nine days of captivity
charles urschel returned home safely
[Music]
as this was the first high-profile
kidnapping after the passing of the
limburg law the fbi were all hands on
deck with the investigation determined
to make an example out of the culprits
they were
chasing down leads all over the country
but in the end it was herschel himself
who served as their greatest asset and
proved instrumental in identifying his
kidnappers the businessman had a great
memory and tried to remember as many
details as possible about his time in
captivity he had heard oil pumps and
barnyard animals outside
he noted that the water had a mineral
taste and also came from a pump outside
he intentionally left his fingerprints
over as many objects as possible to
prove he had been in that location but
the biggest clue of all were the
airplanes
every day herschel heard two airplanes
flying over him every day
except for one when there had been heavy
rain and presumably the flights had been
cancelled but herschel got even more
information by waiting for a few minutes
after a flyover and then
casually asking his captors what time it
was they did not make the connection
and answered him it seemed that the
planes flew over ursula's location
around 9 45 a.m and 5 45 pm every day
except for one rainy day with this
information fbi agents looked over
flight schedules within a 600-mile
radius of oklahoma city and
cross-referenced them with
meteorological data
and discovered that paradise texas fit
the bill when they found out that
catherine kelly's parents had a ranch in
that area
it immediately raised a gianray flag an
fbi agent first visited the ranch under
cover he found enough circumstantial
evidence to justify a raid which was
conducted about a week after herschel's
release
lastly the victim was brought in to
confirm that the ranch was indeed the
place where he had been held captive the
shannons were arrested
as was harvey bailey a bank robber and
friend of kelly's who was at the ranch
nursing an injury following a job
it seems like the shannon ranch was
often used by criminals as a hideout but
neither george kelly nor his wife would
bear during interrogation the shannons
confessed their role in the kidnapping
revealing that it was kelly and albert
bates who were behind it
now the manhunt began and with his face
plastered on every newspaper in the
county machine gun kelly was now the
most wanted man in america albert bates
was the first to get caught he was
arrested in denver on august 12th two
weeks after the kidnapping with some of
the ransom money and
tommy gunn in his possession the
shannons as well as other associates of
the kellys were also taken into custody
in all 21 people would be convicted for
their role in the kidnapping
with another three charged but found
innocent but for now george and
catherine kelly
were still on the run they had disguised
themselves in an attempt to fly under
the radar george had dyed his hair
blonde while his wife wore a red wig
they even traveled with 12 year old
geraldine arnold the daughter of an
acquaintance to make themselves appear
like a nice happy family just exploring
the country by september after going
from city to city the outlaws were
hiding out in memphis at the home of a
man named john tichenor but they needed
money because they didn't have their
share of the ransom on them instead they
buried most of it in caches throughout
texas prior to the raid and didn't have
time to retrieve it before going on the
run kelly convinced his brother-in-law
from his first marriage langford ramsey
to
travel to texas and dig up the cash but
he was unable to do so and the fbi
intercepted their wire messages
the authorities also talked to geraldine
who was sent on a train ride back to her
parents the kellys weren't aware that
the arnolds had already gone to the
police
by that point and now geraldine told
them just where to find the fugitives
on the morning of september 26 1933 the
fbi and memphis police raided john
tichenor's
home and they arrested george and
catherine kelly there are multiple
versions of how this went down with the
most dramatic of all involving the
authorities bursting into the house guns
blazing
and kelly putting his hands up and
shouting don't shoot g-men don't
shoot right off the bat catherine kelly
distanced herself from her husband and
claimed that both she and her family
were innocent and had been
coerced into kidnapping herschel by
machine gun kelly in his gangster pals
nobody bought it though in october 1933
george kelly catherine kelly albert
bates
harvey bailey robert shannon and his
wife aura shannon were all sentenced to
life imprisonment with letter sentences
given to other co-conspirators who would
either a role in the kidnapping or
helped the kelly's evade justice
at the time of his conviction machine
gun kelly was suspected in the shooting
of several policemen
but he was never charged with any of
those crimes albert bates died in prison
harvey bailey served 30 years before
being released
catherine kelly and her mother each
served 25 years before release
changing their names and starting a new
life in oklahoma city as far as machine
gun kelly was concerned he began the
last chapter of his life as prisoner
number 117 in alcatraz
by most accounts he was a model prisoner
perhaps in the hopes of an early release
this never came but he was granted a
small concession
after 17 years in alcatraz kelly was
transferred to the more relaxed
leavenworth penitentiary
where he spent the final four years of
his life he died of a heart attack on
july
18 1954 aged 59. robert shannon his
father-in-law had been released a few
years earlier
brought his body back to the ranch in
paradise texas and
buried him in a nearby cemetery there is
one final secret that kelly took to his
grave the location
of the ransom money almost half of it
has never been recovered and presumably
it's still buried somewhere in texas
just waiting to be found
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe also please do check out
our fantastic sponsor squarespace
link below and thank you for watching